Here's the state of our knowledge
about NP-complete problems,
given just what we proved
in the last lesson.
We've shown that we can take
an arbitrary problem in NP and
reduce it to CNF satisfied ability.
That's what the Cook-Levin theorem said.
We did do another polynomial reduction,
one of the independent set or
clique problem to
the vertex cover problem.
Again, I'm treating Clique and
Independent Set here as one because
the problems are so similar.
Much of the lesson will be
concerned with connecting up
these two links into a chain.
First, we're going to reduce
general CNF SAT to 3-CNF SAT.
Where each clause has
exactly three literals.
This is a critical reduction
because 3 SAT is much
easier to reduce to other
problems than general CNF SAT.
Then we're going to reduce
3-CNF to independent set and
by transitivity this will show that
this whole chain here is NP complete.
Note that this is very convenient
because it would have been pretty messy
to try to reduce every problem to
NP to these problems directly.
Finally, we will reduce 3-CNF
SAT to the Subset Sum problem
to give you a fuller sense of the types
of arguments that go into reductions.